breaking news on the investigation into
the january 6 assault on the capitol cbs
news and the washington post have
obtained white house records of
president trump's activities that day
and they reveal
a nearly eight-hour gap in entries in
his call log and his daily diary this
gap raises big questions about what the
president was doing at the time and
whether he was using a so-called burner
phone maybe a couple of them those are
disposable and untraceable
chief election and campaign
correspondent robert costa this is his
reporting along with bob woodward of the
washington post and robert joins us now
bob good to see you you break another
big story here good morning
good morning we have obtained 11 pages
of internal white house records from the
day of the attack that were turned over
to the january 6 committee they show for
the first time a detailed and official
account of trump's phone calls and
behind the scenes activities that day
they also notably contain a gap in the
official records during the assault
something is missing since the gap
stands in contrast to extensive public
reporting about his calls at the time
as chaos engulfed the capitol building
on january 6th president trump spoke
repeatedly on the phone with allies and
supporters some of whom urged him to put
an end to the violence but none of those
calls are reflected in the 11 pages of
those white house records for january 6
given to the house select committee
there is a massive 7 hour and 37 minute
gap in calls from 11 17 a.m to 6 54 p.m
which includes the most violent period
of the attack
cbs news has confirmed at least two
calls during the attack that do not
appear on the phone log or the daily
diary one call from trump to utah
republican mike lee and another call to
trump from house republican leader kevin
mccarthy who described it to nora
o'donnell by phone as the violence was
unfolding the committee is now
investigating whether the president and
top aides use so-called burner or
disposable phones to avoid scrutiny of
their calls during that time
the logs do show several incoming and
outgoing calls on the morning of january
6th including from rudy giuliani and
former president trump's chief
strategist steve bannon at 8 37 a.m
trump spoke with bannon whose sources
say told him to call vice president mike
pence and urge him to block
certification of the election trump
later did phone pence failing to
persuade him but that call is not listed
in the records there is a listing at 11
17 a.m the president talked on a phone
call to an unidentified person cbs news
has learned the pence call was in that
time frame there's also a lengthy gap in
records of the former president's
movements during the attack as recorded
in his daily diary at 1 21 p.m the
records note the president met with his
valet that notation signifies the
president's return to the oval office
from the rally the next entry isn't
until 403 the president went to the rose
garden it reads where he participated in
a video message to supporters this was a
fraudulent election
but we can't play into the hands of
these people
we have to have peace
so go home bob woodward said uncovering
former president trump's actions in
those nearly eight hours will be a key
part of the committee's investigation
these records
seem to have disappeared this is the day
when they are protesting
the january 6th
effort to certify
who's president
and the certification was that joe biden
won
and
a thousand people attacked the capitol
right at that time
that there's this gap who was he talking
to what was he doing
last night trump said in his statement
quote i have no idea what a burner phone
is to the best of my knowledge i have
never even heard the term and quote a
trump spokesperson said that trump had
nothing to do with the records and
assumed any and all of his phone calls
were recorded and preserved
oh boy bob it's an unusual morning when
you're saying president of the united
states and burner phone in the same
sentence it's also an unusual morning
when you're talking about a federal
judge in california ruling just
yesterday that former president trump
likely committed end quote multiple
crimes in his efforts to stop congress
from certifying president biden's 2020
election victory what more can you tell
us about that
tony it's a very serious statement judge
david carter ruled that he found it
quote more likely than not unquote that
trump and his legal adviser john eastman
engaged in criminal conduct as they
pushed pence in congress to hold off on
certification carter wrote quote if dr
eastman and president trump's plan had
worked it would have permanently ended
the peaceful transition of power
undermining american democracy and the
constitution he added if the country
does not commit to pursuing
accountability for those responsible the
court fears january 6 will repeat itself
in a statement eastman's attorney said
his client has an unblemished record as
an attorney and disagrees with the
judge's findings
the investigation continues at least
until the midterms bob thank you very
much thank you